[Música]
Estados Unidos vive la recta final de la
campaña para las elecciones de medio
término de este martes 8 de noviembre el
estado de Pensilvania se antoja como uno
de los escenarios clave en el que la
disputa entre republicanos y demócratas
Aún está ajustada
la huelga por la realización del censo
en 2023 en Bolivia ya cumple dos semanas
en varias zonas del territorio luego de
comenzar en la región de Santa Cruz
entre tanto el país se enfrenta a un
desabastecimiento de gasolina
inicia la cop27 en Egipto con la
compensación económica a los países más
vulnerables en materia climática como
uno de sus principales retos varios
países de América Latina entre ellos
analizamos la importancia de la
emergencia climática en la región
Bienvenidos a este nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Soy
Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos empezamos en Estados Unidos
donde Este martes 8 de noviembre tendrán
lugar las elecciones de medio término
este sábado las principales figuras
políticas del país se posaron en
Pensilvania en donde la lucha entre los
candidatos de ambos partidos para el
congreso Aún está muy reñida los
expresidentes Donald Trump y Barack
Obama estuvieron apoyando a sus
respectivos candidatos junto Obama
estuvo también el actual mandatario Joe
biden
la democracia está literalmente en la
boleta electoral Este es un momento
decisivo para la nación y todos Debemos
hablar con una sola voz
independientemente de nuestro partido el
pronóstico arrojan unos resultados muy
ajustados para esas elecciones y la
llave de la mayoría del Congreso la
podrían tener los hispanos en Estados
como Georgia donde hace dos años los
demócratas ganaron por la mínima han
intensificado las campañas enfocadas a
esta comunidad también las visitas
puerta a puerta para informarlos sobre
el proceso electoral Y cómo votar tanto
nivel chinos trae la historia
Hola buenos días estos jóvenes están
preparando para una intensa jornada de
trabajo Se dirigen a un barrio hispano A
las afueras de Atlanta para promover el
voto de esta comunidad en las próximas
elecciones de medio término aún a que
solo una hora de Atlanta después
encontrar a comunidades marginalizadas
que nunca han nunca nunca se han
involucrado con el voto o han empujado a
sus oficiales a hacer un cambio
están haciendo campaña puerta a Puerta
durante todo el día no tienen afiliación
política el objetivo es educar a la
población que muchas veces ni habla
inglés sobre cómo votar y cómo funciona
el proceso electoral en Estados Unidos
los invitamos a que se informen a que
chequen las propuestas de los candidatos
en base a eso ellos toman una mejor
decisión que les beneficie como latinos
los hispanos en Georgia unos 350.000
podrían acabar decidiendo la mayoría del
senado como pasó hace dos años en los
comicios de 2020 por 11.000 votos de
diferencia los demócratas acabaron
liderando la cámara alta el escenario se
podría repetir porque no está claro el
color político de esta región
Porque aquí se va a decidir de un
senador y sabemos que estamos a 50
entonces republicano y demócrata
entonces todo el mundo quiere ver quién
va a ganar porque eso puede decidir el
desde esta asociación que durante varias
décadas se ha volcado en las elecciones
y los latinos están viendo como ambas
campañas se han focalizado más que nunca
en la comunidad hispana y también que
los candidatos no es suficiente mandar
algo en el correo es yendo a dónde están
ellos para decir esta es mi cara me ves
en la televisión pero yo soy persona yo
estoy aquí para escuchar sí como apuntan
los pronósticos los resultados son tan
ajustados se confirmará que los latinos
también deciden el rumbo de Estados
Unidos seguirán siendo una minoría por
ahora pero con mucha más fuerza
en noticias de América Latina la huelga
por la realización del censo en 2023 en
Bolivia ya cumple dos semanas en varias
zonas del país luego de comenzar en la
región de Santa Cruz la más poblada de
Bolivia y uno de sus motores económicos
a pesar de los intentos de diálogo entre
manifestantes y el gobierno aún no se ha
llegado a una solución entre tanto el
país se enfrenta un desabastecimiento de
gasolina y al aumento de los precios de
algunos productos
15 días de tensión política en Santa
Cruz la región más poblada de Bolivia la
huelga que demanda la realización de un
censo en 2023 ya cumple dos semanas
con batas blancas y banderas bolivianas
el sector hospitalario se sumó a las
protestas del viernes desde Cochabamba
en el centro del país aseguran que
buscan apoyar a los cruceños
Santa Cruz tenemos que ponderar la gran
pelea que está llevando a cabo
defendiéndose de una avasallamiento del
gobierno no podemos permitir que un
hermano departamento en la greda unas
movilizaciones que ahora abarcan
múltiples demandas
ya que hemos visto la represión
que se
están tomando contra el pueblo cruceño
que está encabezando esta lucha
ciudadana y esta lucha cívica la
realización del censo es un tema
sensible en Bolivia los manifestantes
aseguran que el subregistro está
afectando a ciertas regiones ya que la
cantidad de personas de cada
departamento determina la asignación de
recursos y también los puestos en el
parlamento el gobierno reiterado la
necesidad de hacer el censo en 2024 un
año después de lo que demandan los
manifestantes bajo el pretexto de tener
cifras más precisas una postura
defendida por sectores oficialistas que
se han opuesto a las movilizaciones
derivando en fuertes enfrentamientos las
dos partes se han sentado en múltiples
ocasiones a dialogar Pero todas las
conversaciones han resultado fallidas
las consecuencias del paro ya se sienten
en el país el desabastecimiento de
gasolina en algunas partes de Bolivia es
una realidad generando preocupación en
la población por el aumento de los
precios de recursos básicos el
presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro
firmó la ley que permitirá a su la
concentración iniciar negociaciones con
todos los grupos armados ilegales para
lograr la denominada paz total Petro
busca así desmarcarse del anterior
gobierno de Iván Duque criticado por
implementar el acuerdo de paz de manera
lenta y selectiva
era su mayor Promesa de campaña el
presidente Gustavo Petro firmó la ley
418 el marco jurídico de la paz total en
Colombia una tarea difícil para el jefe
de estado no solo para negociar con las
guerrillas como el eln pero también con
los grupos paramilitares la violencia en
Colombia afecta a muchas poblaciones
forzando la gente a huir de sus casas
aquí en el cauca los combatientes del Ln
y del Clan del Golfo se disputan a
sangre y fuego los poblados que bordean
la ruta para el tráfico de cocaína los
desplazados quieren la paz pero siguen
siendo realistas tenemos esperanza en el
nuevo presidente que ojalá pues
cumpla y prometa que no solamente es
prometer hay que prometer y hay que
cumplir y es mejor no prometer y cumplir
preguntamos al director ejecutivo del
centro de estudios en seguridad y paz en
Colombia Néstor rosanía si el gobierno
de petróleo iba a cumplir esta nueva ley
nos explicó que era un esfuerzo
necesario hacia la paz a pesar de su
pesimismo lo mismo pasó más de 30 años
con el Cartel de Cali El Cartel de Cali
negoció con el gobierno y apareció el
cartel del Norte del Valle y una nueva
espiral de la violencia entonces lo que
vamos a tener Es que muchos grupos
armados irán negociará con el gobierno
Pedro Pero los que están abajo en la
pirámide esos van a armar nuevos grupos
y va a seguir Cuál es el piso esto el
negocio de narcotráfico sobre el
narcotráfico Petro prometió un cambio de
paradigma quiere impulsar la sustitución
de cultivos ilícitos y prohibir la
dispersión aérea con glifosato pero la
multitud de los actores y la complejidad
del territorio podrían comprometer el
sueño de paz del nuevo gobierno de
Colombia
desde este domingo tendrá lugar en
Egipto la cop27 uno de los principales
retos de esta conferencia del clima es
la compensación económica a los países
más vulnerables en materia climática por
sus esfuerzos para mitigar este fenómeno
entre ellos muchos de América Latina
anteriormente hablamos con Roberto rojo
biólogo de la Universidad Autónoma de
México quien nos comentaba el camino que
debe seguir la región para compaginar el
desarrollo económico con el cuidado
medioambiental
Claro que sí pero tenemos que cambiar el
paradigma el desarrollo económico no es
lo principal tenemos que cambiar ese
paradigma tenemos que velar por la
conservación de los ecosistemas que son
los que nos dan vida sino cambiamos la
idea y nos decidimos a preservar los
ecosistemas la cuestión económica que
viene en segundo término pues
simplemente no no la vamos a tener una
vez que perdemos la salud ecosistémica
lo que sigue es perder la salud humana y
lo próximo es perder la salud económica
Entonces sí tenemos que detonar la
economía en estos países pero de una
manera inteligente de una manera donde
prioricemos la naturaleza porque somos
parte de la naturaleza no estamos ajenos
a ella dependemos directamente de la
naturaleza y en la medida que
preservamos nuestros ecosistemas y
América Latina con cuenta con países
megadiversos en esa medida es como vamos
a tener un futuro sustentable o
sostenible y que vamos a tener todo el
desarrollo económico que necesitemos
pero para eso debemos cambiar la idea y
no enfocarnos en el desarrollo económico
sino en la preservación de la naturaleza
y después ya por consecuencia tendremos
desarrollo y crecimiento
hasta aquí este informativo sigan con
nuestra programación
[Música]